let me ask you this i i want to get back
a moment and and
revisit the kovid 19 because that you
know you ran
on uh very strongly on the border that
that was a single issue for you the
pandemic hadn't happened
biden ran strongly on covid19
yet i'm learning from chad wolfe your
former acting dhs secretary and
democrats as well that people are
crossing the border
and sometimes we can test them and
sometimes we can't so as a former
president you know a lot of details that
we don't have access right now to
because we haven't had our first solo
news conference with biden so i'm going
to ask you a couple of questions
just from a president's perspective
title 42
what would it do to stem the tide in
terms of covid19 right now and is it
being applied in your estimation
you created that they're applying
nothing
they're not doing title 42 or any title
people are just pouring into our country
and they will destroy our country
they will destroy our country you can't
take millions of people they'll have
millions of people before this mess is
over
and they've got some kind of a political
theory i guess that it's a good thing
maybe i don't think it is i think it's a
very bad thing for our country
again we want people to come in but they
have to be able to help our country they
have to come in through merit
and they have to come in legally right
now you don't have anything
protecting our country you have people
just flowing through
coming through and they're so that the
numbers are so vast nobody's ever seen
anything like it they said 20 years
i'll bet you it's maybe forever maybe
it's uh you know
from the beginning of this whole mess
but it's much more than 20 years they
said the worst in 20 years
no they're going to destroy our country
in other ways too if you look at what's
going on
you're going to have back the court
montana but big tax increases
they're going to take your guns away i
mean take a look at what they're doing
with uh
take a look at what's coming up and i
predicted it all now i must say
i never thought that biden and it's not
biden it's other people that are you
know putting stuff in front of them
but i never thought that i never thought
that biden in a million years
would be worse nobody did would be far
worse than bernie sanders this is
bernie sanders on steroids this is what
he's doing
with all and you haven't seen anything
yet so the second amendment is going to
be obliterated
the and there's no stopping them and and
our leadership
mitch isn't strong enough to stop people
never was that's
like one of the big secrets but he had
the majority but now that he's
not in the majority he's not uh he's not
doing his thing he's not doing what he
should be doing uh there are ways to
stop
some of this stuff that's happening but
you're going to see packing the courts
you're going to see
the biggest tax increase in history
you're going to see
the second amendment just absolutely
obliterated
you're going to see many other things
the green new deal will be put into
effect
people used to laugh at it when it was
proposed three years ago by people that
knew nothing about the environment by
the way
and they're going to raise taxes to a
level and they're going to spend a lot
of their money foolishly on green new
deal stuff
that doesn't work i i want to ask my
team to put up a couple of numbers and
and we're showing some information for
our viewers
uh mr president as you're talking and
and matching up a little bit you were
talking about the surge at the border
let's go back to southwest border uh
adults up 188 percent
and unaccompanied minors i want to talk
about the children
because that's the mark against our soul
and your administration
took criticism because we were taking in
unaccompanied minors and they were
getting separated from the adults
at the border and you see that everybody
on the screen 92 percent increase of
unaccompanied minors now
in 2021 versus 2020 we're only three
months in
so as we look at the screen i want to
match that now
mr president when you look at these
numbers
and you look at what wiped away on the
first day of
president biden's administration and
executive order
what exactly were you doing that was
working better than what we see now and
i understand
that people were flowing over now but
there were some things that you did
you had agreements with honduras ecuador
guatemala
mexico i i want the audience to
understand
some of what was wiped away more than
just well it had my name on it because
those numbers that we're looking at now
are a mark against us those children
their lives are forever different
if they make it well first of all i mean
the only problem with giving you this
answer is you don't have enough time
because uh
you know you need about two hours to
explain what we've done what we did is
is incredible but you know in a nutshell
i do want to start off by saying that
they built the cages
they built cages for children we didn't
build them they built them
and the famous picture appeared about
the cages that were built and then
fortunately somebody remembered
and fortunately we have guys like morgan
and and tom how good i mean we have such
professionals tom homan we have such
great professionals i watch them on your
show
uh they really know their business and
they're you know
they're not involved in this they have
people that have no idea but
they built cages in 2014 but that was
during the
obama administration and they blamed
them
on us we didn't build the cages they did
uh very sad you know when they had a
picture in the new york times of
children in cages and it turned out that
it was them and the newspapers didn't
want to do retractions even though now
everybody knows that's the fact
but as far as uh other countries are
concerned so we had
uh guatemala honduras el salvador
and others uh we were paying those three
countries approximately 500 million
dollars a year who knows what they were
doing with the money you could imagine
they were supposed to use that money for
economic development keep people there
it all sounds good but it you know it
wasn't being used for that and people
were flowing in and they wouldn't take
ms-13 gang members back they wouldn't
take anybody back
for obama they wouldn't do it they they
said nope don't ever land your plane
here don't ever bring your buses here
don't
ever send a boat nothing we won't take
them back
turn around they were turning our people
around they were treating us like
like uh amateurs like which is what they
were
and so i said well let me they was doing
that at the beginning of mine too i said
so how much money do we pay these
countries 500 million dollars i said
stop payment
as soon as i stopped payment all of a
sudden they said we would welcome our
ms-13 gang members back into our country
we were welcome
anyway i got along very well with those
three countries and
and really well with mexico the
president of mexico is a friend of mine
he's a great guy
excuse me because i i know i'm gonna
have to let you go soon but i want to
get this in there is that part of what's
gone
i mean is biden uh maintaining these
relationships we can't do this without
the country south of the border in fact
we had some video and we can go back
uh to tijuana mexico there are
ten cities that have set up on the
border waiting to get back into the
united states
all those people are going to come
flooding in right i kept them in mexico
by keeping them in mexico
mexico becomes much tougher at their
northern border because they don't want
any more
so i said to mexico look if you're not
if you're going to do any of this stuff
that's bad for us i'm going to put
tariffs on all the cars that you make
for the united states
because before my administration they
sold 32 percent of our automaking
business the unions don't realize that
you know
the union members realize it but the
heads of the unions that all support
democrats
no matter who they are they don't
realize it but they took 32
of our automobile business i said all
those cars that you make are going to be
tariffs
so mexico was great i must tell you
mexico was great
the relationship was great
well no i don't know we can tell that
they're not doing they have a field day
they have people that are rank amateurs
they have people that talk about
ideology but it's not even good ideology
why would it work
why are we supposed to take care of the
world and in many cases the world's
criminals and they're coming over not
from the three countries plus mexico
they're coming over now from yemen
they're coming over from the middle east
who the hell knows what we're taking
it these people are destroying our
country i said it was going to happen
during the campaign
that's why i got 75 million votes
probably much more than that
and it's a disgrace what's been allowed
to happen to our country
and they're persecuting people they're
stopping them from talking they're
stopping free speech
and they're personally let's get into
that great americans
let's get into that now let's get into
the fact that as media we cannot get
into this border situation
that there is a lid on us with regard to
those facilities
did your administration ever consider
some of the things that the biden
administration is doing
closing down a border i still don't
understand by the way mr president how
that would even really work if it's so
porous the way it is
you can't close that's why you needed
the wall but now i've built almost 500
miles of wall
so it's a much easier situation now when
i took it over it was a disaster
but i built 500 miles of wall and now
you know you have vast sections i mean
you see some openings but
the openings get closed that's what the
purpose is you have to close them
those contracts have been given a long
time ago and again that was to get
people through
but these are small openings but uh that
has to get close but
the wall has made it so much easier for
these people
and frankly i mean i even hear they want
to tear down the wall if you can even
believe it tear down the wall you know
this is
uh not not the way you heard it from
ronald reagan